i took a test a lateral flow and it was
positive
and then i did a uh
i took my temperature it was slightly
raised it was a temperature of 100.
and then but i thought you know what i'm
fine i'll be all right
went to bed woke up the next day i was
not [ __ ] fine mate
[Music]
hello and welcome to a special episode
of trigonometry yes indeed welcome back
it's been a while since we recorded one
of these and we are going to get into
the reason why that was which is of
course that we just both had covered
didn't we francis we did it was exciting
times not really no it wasn't actually
it wasn't great times but let's start
with how we we got it we think yeah we
did we attended that sex party yeah
which was great but that's nothing to do
with covington no but seriously we did
our brilliant live show the last live
show of 2021 with aisha canby which i
thoroughly enjoyed it was really great
uh and then we hugged and kissed and we
[ __ ]
took pictures essentially consensually
yeah thanks mate you're specifying that
makes that even worse mate we're
comedians we need to specify we took
pictures we're not left-wing comedians
so it's different but we took pictures
with about 200 people yeah uh probably
more than that uh then we hung around
for a bit uh etc and then we came back
to the studio and we had a few friends
around literally maybe five or six other
people and had a bit of a party to
celebrate our last live show of the year
which is where i think we got covered
indeed so what happened and i'll do my
timeline and then you do yours so i was
i remember in the evening feeling a
little bit starting to feel a bit ropey
but all right woke up the next day
felt okay did i went to a few places did
a few things and by the evening i was
starting to feel really rough
really bad so what did you do you went
to see a comedy show yeah i did and
spread it to everybody no i was i i
didn't really i didn't think i just saw
at the time that i just felt a little
bit under the weather and a little bit
tired and then to be fair we haven't had
a holiday for ages we've been flat out
we worked hard all year yeah it would
not be unusual for you to be able to run
down yeah so that's all i felt i felt a
bit run down and then i went to see the
comedy show came back made me feel worse
which is what comedy does to me now and
then
i went back to my girlfriend's house
and then
i took i took a test a lateral flow and
it was positive
and then i did
i took my temperature it was slightly
raised it was a temperature of a hundred
and then but i thought you know what i'm
fine i'll be all right
went to bed woke up the next day i was
not [ __ ] fine mate i was
absolutely done in
temperature of 104 degrees
the bed was covered in sweat not in a
good way and i remember like you see
what's what's bed covered in sweat in a
good way you know when you're
mate
i'm physically fit i don't sweat that
much even when i'm having a good well
i'm not so anyway
[Laughter]
so anyway and then i remember like we
were messaging on on our on our group on
the whatsapp yeah and you saying right
well we've got to have a contingency
plan obviously okay so can we gonna have
a meeting can you join the meeting and i
felt terrible because i didn't say can
you desire i said like are you up for
something like that yeah i wasn't trying
to force you to join him
no no no absolutely you were and um and
i felt terrible because i was just in no
way able to join in any type of meeting
yeah and
what i didn't expect from covert is for
it to knock me
as it did and i was completely out of
action
for a week done well we should say we're
recording this on the 2nd of january
we
covered on the 11th of december so it's
now been over 3 weeks and i would say
we're very close to being fully
recovered now
but even so i haven't done any vigorous
exercise yet um i still have a bit of a
lingering cough even though i'm not
infectious and negative for blah blah
blah so it took us three over three
weeks to recover and we'll maybe
talk once once you've given the timeline
about what it was like as well yeah so
the first second day i was really ill
really really really sick
um
and i i just cut i couldn't i i just
couldn't move i couldn't move the only
thing i could do
was go to lou come back drink water i
didn't have anything to eat nothing
wednesday
again pretty much the same and then i
came back here
and
from then on in
it was a gradual process of getting
better but it took a long time and one
thing that
i was quite shocked about is that
i didn't have a desire to eat for about
two weeks
just that is shocking
i remember i bought a lovely de shoon
for me and anton anton very much enjoyed
it i picked out the prawns out my porn
curry and that was it and what were some
of your your symptoms i mean
what we i mean here we go so we had a
temperature of 104 my digestive system
was completely done in i think that's as
far as we need to take that
i was i had a really bad cough that at
one point i was coughing up blood
and i called up one one one and they
assuaged my fears by going just so you
know mr foster uh one of the very rare
symptoms of covid is blood clots on the
lungs so you coughing up blood might be
a sign that you've got a blood clot on
the lung so you're going to have to go
to a e i actually do think that's
unlikely because a blood clot would be
in a blood vessel yeah so i'm not sure
that that makes sense maybe i'm wrong
i'm not medical expert but but it's i
mean coughing up blood is not a good
thing no it's not even the fact that you
do it it's just that you look down at
the seat you go yeah i am not in good
shape yeah and then i said to anton i
said we're gonna have to go to a e anton
went no problem i'll get a zip car turns
up outside the flat it's a van
so
if it was me i'd put you in the [ __ ]
booth
so literally he was in the front and i
was in the back of the van getting
knocked about like that well that's how
it should have been we needed to keep
anton away from it by the way anton was
at the same party didn't catch kovid no
that's it mate scouts genes are strong
greek genes maybe yeah greek scouse well
anyway so you had to go to hospital yeah
uh they gave you some antibiotics for
what this was the thing right i turned
up at a hospital right and then they
were like okay i'm saying i'm covered
positive i was wearing i was wearing a
proper mask you know that my friend had
given me leather one yeah exactly and
then we went to another to they went
right you need to go to this particular
part of the hospital so we went there i
registered and i went oh where am i
gonna wait they went outside
so like for 40 minutes i was outside in
a bleakly cold december just waiting to
get seen by the doctor who when i went
to see him and he went to examine he
would examine me was [ __ ] furious
why because i had covered
uh okay
he wasn't impressed so if you had aids
you'd be fine yeah i think so
yeah fair enough because it's not an
airborne virus mate okay what if you had
a bowler i mean i think that the
protocol would have been slapping in
fairness he is a doctor he signed up to
treat people who have disease what do
you think she's gonna get a bunch of
[ __ ] catwalk models turn up in
bikinis perfectly healthy just to
entertain them is that it was the most
perfunctory lung exam or you just went
breathe breathe breathe you've got no
you've got no blood clots here's some
antibiotics get out because he said you
had a chest infection yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay cool and uh you came back
and you gradually kept recovering and i
gradually kept recovering and i remember
once saying to anton anton do i look
better and he just looked at me and went
no
but yeah but gradually and then until we
are where we are so so those are some of
the symptoms and i think we should also
talk a lot and i'll talk about this when
i'm talking about me the fact that
covert
then actually dr john wyatt who we had
on the show he said this at the time and
i didn't really pay much attention to it
but he did say that any disease of that
nature that causes you to lose your
sense of smell or taste
means it's affecting your mind well not
your mind your brain and therefore your
mind to some extent
everybody knows that one of the symptoms
about covid is that it you lose your
sense of smell and taste
that is proof that can only happen when
the virus has actually gone into your
central nervous system
so
it is there it has invaded the central
nervous system what is it doing there
nobody knows is it possible that it's
actually going to have an impact which
comes apparent 10 20 years time there
are other examples of infections of
virus infections which only showed
neurological symptoms 20 years later
30 40 years later is it possible we're
going to have an epidemic of some weird
neurological
conditions even dementia or motor
neurone disease or multiple sclerosis
which was actually been triggered by
minor infections which people didn't
even notice
so i think you were very anxious yeah uh
as well which to be fair you you're
naturally you lean that way it's not a
thing that i have i i'm more sort of
irritable and impatient uh which
amplified massively for me
uh but for you anxiety was the thing
that you i had a panic attack there was
one particular day where i i was just i
remember just going into the just going
into my bathroom and just feeling a cold
sweat come over me
just a cold sweat there's a lot about
sweating in this episode guys no but but
the reason i bring it up is i think
people might well you know people have
panic attacks yeah irrespective of
whatever but i think
in my experience and having observed
other people around me and you and
others in terms of how covert affects
people mentally
is it seems to amplify
at least for some people their
pre-existing
issues
what i'm trying to get at is you would
not have had a panic attack if this had
been a cold probably
so it wasn't like you were scared about
covid because you'd read something in
the newspaper it was more like
physically it was making you anxious it
was like [ __ ] with your brain it was
making me anxious by [ __ ] my brain
and this is the thing that people don't
talk enough about it's the isolationary
aspect of it that really gets you that
does you in yeah after about six or
seven days and you're starting to feel
better but you can't see anyone you
can't talk to anyone you can't socialize
it's really tough
really really really tough well i i and
this is another thing so
i caught uh i caught it probably at the
same time as you and i did the lateral
flow when you did yours but i had no
symptoms at this point and mine was
negative
and i was like okay so i probably would
have been around the virus blah blah
blah so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
do all the right things i'm gonna
you know drink my
tea with lemon and honey and and to go
to bed early and get some rest and drink
plenty of fluids and i went to bed and i
wake up the next day and i felt
absolutely fine
uh so i was like okay cool i've beaten
this covert that i may or may not have
had uh great time to you know get
because i'm an active person i like to
do things so i went out and i did lots
of stuff i did some shopping for for
christmas i went and got a christmas
tree i did a bunch of different things
um and
that was not a good idea because by the
evening i had a fever yeah and at this
point i think it was sort of like i'd i
defeated it initially but then i did too
much stuff because i did have the sense
that i should just rest
and then by the evening i had a bit of a
fever and instead of like taking more
fluids and going to bed i was just like
oh you know i've got stuff to do so i
did some work stuff i stayed up until
like two in the morning doing things etc
which i sometimes do and then i woke up
the next day and i was properly ill as
well
and i didn't have a fever quite as high
as yours but basically for the next
three days i had a fever and the only
thing that i could do is be in bed and
drink flu
liquids and that was it
and after three days i started feeling
better i still had a bit of a fever but
but i was much better i was able to get
up and walk around
so idiot that i am
i started doing stuff again i started
you know getting up playing games i
wasn't doing that much work but i was
doing a little bit
and that was a big mistake because uh
trying to work through having this
disease
really didn't go well for me and i know
anecdotally of many other people who did
the same they're mma fighters who are
super fit but because they tried to
fight through it instead of getting rest
they had it much worse and that's what
happened to me so i had it quite badly
but not particularly badly for a few
days
then i started to recover and i started
doing stuff
and then after about two or three days
of oh i can just carry on with my life i
then felt really bad again
and i started to notice a lot of
physical and mental symptoms that i was
just observing that were quite weird so
i'm normally someone who likes the the
space to be quite warm like we joke
about in the studio i'm always hanging
out by the radiator
i actually couldn't really feel cold
that much
at all in in a way that was not normal
for me but i physically could not stand
to be in any space where there was a
draft
so obviously i was trying to keep the
space ventilated and whatever but the
moment my wife opened the window
somewhere in the flat i would literally
feel like i'm about to die
it's just a horrible physical feeling
another thing obviously my wife being
pregnant i i said to her from day one
you've got to stay away from me i know
you're you'll be bringing me stuff and
you're worried about me whatever but you
got to stay away from me
and
because of that that isolation aspect
that you talk about i remember one time
she could see that i was really not
having a good time and she just like
came and sort of threw a
semi-closed door like touched me on the
back and i nearly burst out crying which
is very unusual for me uh because of
that lack of physical contact but i
don't think it's just the lack of
physical contact i think mentally
there's something about this disease
that makes you feel very alone and i
don't know what it is it could be that
you know
we've we've whipped up a frenzy around
how you mustn't be around people and
whatever
or it could be just that that's what it
does
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthony has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
but mentally as well
see i've still got a little bit of a
lingering cough
now i noticed that
i've done a lot of personal development
stuff i've really learned to understand
my own mind inside out and one of the
things that people always teach you
about how to manage your own mental
well-being is that you've got to learn
to understand that your mind is not you
so when you experience an emotion
you you've got to realize that there's
someone else that's observing that
experience happening and so
when i see myself reacting in ways that
are unnatural i don't go this is me i am
scared i go
oh that's interesting i'm i'm
there's the feeling of fear
or the feeling of whatever and i i
started to notice that um
my emotions were
very different to my normal self so in
addition to amplifying my irritability
and the fact that i can get angry about
stuff that's not worth getting angry
about and stuff like that
i also noticed that
i felt very emotional
you know
i was drawn to watching movies that were
very sad yeah like all of that stuff
which is very unusual for me i normally
really don't care about it so mentally
it was having an effect as well i find
that very interesting that you said that
that it
exacerbates
the parts of your
you the parts of your mental condition
which are not as strong i know people
who have depression covet exacerbated
their depression with me it's anxiety it
absolutely exacerbated it and
and and like we said before the fact
that you are on your own all the time
i've got no problem with being on mine
you know a day on my own great you get
to do stuff you get to whatever you get
to sort your life out but 10 days on
your own
after about the fifth or sixth day it
starts to become wearing well if you
think about it i mean putting people in
isolation is a form of torture yeah well
well known and well practiced but but
like i say i don't think it's just that
yeah if you were healthy you could
manage five or six days on your own yeah
and it'd be fine yeah
and also you'd be able to go out and do
stuff
and also the other mental
thing that i noticed is once uh i got to
a point where i i want so i tested
negative initially then the next day
when i had symptoms i tested positive
and then i did a pcr test that i ordered
that didn't arrive for about three or
four days god bless the government and
then i didn't really want to go out for
a few days because i wasn't feeling well
but eventually probably about eight or
nine days after i first caught
the disease and got the symptoms
i went out because you're allowed to go
to the post office to post it and i
remember walking out
and i was looking at people and and you
had the ex the exact same experience the
first time you went out and i nearly
burst into tears because i was like oh
there's there's a world of healthy
people that's how it felt yeah i
remember just walking along the river
near our flat
and just looking out across the river
and just being awestruck because
all i had known
is the confines of the flat and bless
anton who looked after me and you know
and got me food and all the rest of it
but i i remember him saying to me you
can be in the flat it's okay we
you can just sit at one end just open
the window yeah and then you can sit and
the ability just to be able to sit and
if even if he was working on an episode
or doing something but knowing there was
another human being in the room
i mean
it made it so much more bearable yeah
now
the other thing about it i find very odd
for me it's extremely unusual is we had
uh some of our staff getting in touch
asking questions what do we do about
this what do we do about that and i
literally for me this is unheard of
because i think it's fair to say that
i'm sort of like the big picture part of
the course and i manage all of that yeah
and i love doing it i love working with
our team i love going we need to do this
we need to do that let's let's work it
out and people were contacting me and i
literally had to just say
guys i'm ill i can't do like you're just
gonna have to wait or or resolve this
yourself that to me was shocking because
that's not how i am yeah i'm never like
that yeah but but that's how it was now
i should say what before we go on as
well like
i know what we're describing sounds bad
and and that's because it was very
unpleasant i have to this day i used to
say this before we caught cover the
second time i'll say it again
i have had flu worse than this yeah i
have
but but my point is the one of the
realizations for me
was that
when people talk about even omicron
which i still suspect is the variant
that we had being mild
what they mean is you didn't have to go
to hospital and stay in hospital it does
not necessarily mean you're gonna have
an easy time of it now i never thought
it was you know gonna kill us or
anything like that but it was unpleasant
for sure it was very very very
unpleasant and
i i think the people who have just said
you know we hear this word mild and we
inevitably think oh headache and a runny
nose yeah but medically mild essentially
it's like you said you don't end up in
hospital but that doesn't mean that it's
not desperately unpleasant
and also as well
we trivialize flu we go it's a bit of
flu flu i've had mates have been
hospitalized for
are actually very fit healthy people and
then caught covered the next year and
didn't have a problem yeah and you know
we're we're fine we're you know they
still rough but they were fine with it
yeah so i think that with the we
trivialized both flu and coverage once i
made this very important to remember
yeah we trivialized both of these
illnesses and go oh it's flu it's what
they're both you know quite seriously if
you don't treat them well yeah or you're
you're vulnerable in some way to them
yes i agree however the reason i think
we do that is we accept that it's part
of life yeah we accept that you are
throughout the course of your life going
to get through
probably 10 15 20 30 times yes it's just
going to happen yeah
and we'll talk more about the the
conclusions that we draw from it but one
of them for me particularly seeing how
infectious omicron has been because when
we had it
like everyone had it like everyone i
knew had it
like
probably 30 or 40 people that i
personally know including former guests
and people friends and whatever all had
it yeah so one of the conclusions for me
is
look the reality is
everyone's gonna this there is a
pandemic of of highly contagious disease
airborne disease airborne disease
everyone's gonna get it yeah so you the
the con one of the conclusions i think
we all reached here is we gotta make
sure that our physical and mental health
is absolutely at its peak and we've got
to protect ourselves
in that way because i don't think
no amount of
you know being careful wearing a mask
that most of which don't even work it's
so social whatever like you're going to
live your life yeah and you're probably
going to catch it exactly and this idea
of zero covid for me it's it's
ridiculous because you're trying to deny
a biological fact you can't stop the
spread of an airborne virus
you might remember at the start of this
whole thing the whole purpose of
lockdown wasn't to stop it it was to
slow the spread because everybody knows
you can't stop it well right the idea
was you want to spread out
the disease over time but the same
number of people are still going to
catch it and that to me is probably what
is happening and will happen yeah and
this idea that you know we're going to
have you know not that we adopt this
policy adopted this policy in this
country but the idea like we've seen it
in new zealand or australia zero covert
i'm sorry it's for the birds it's it's
just not gonna happen it's it's it's an
impossibility yeah especially in this
globalized world of us what you think
you're going to stop an airborne virus
from coming in yeah and look at the i
mean we'll talk about the restrictions
but look at what's happening in europe
right now they've got vaccine passports
restrictions stay at home vaccinated
[ __ ] going and what you know i nearly
said going in the camps but pretty much
yeah right they've got more cases and
more disease and more deaths than we do
in this country you know so just look at
whales they're locking everything down
and they had vacs possible yes yeah so
in many ways i'm sure people will want
to know our opinion my opinion about all
of the authoritarianism that covert has
engendered hasn't changed one bit if
anything like i say i think everyone's
going to get it so the the the priority
for me is to protect yourself by being
in peak physical condition peak mental
condition for a lot of people that will
also mean being vaccinated because there
are people who are so vulnerable
to this disease that that was a thing
for them and look i
i've always been
very much
sort of like natural immunity but this
is showing me you can catch cover twice
uh particularly after you've you had it
a long time ago we had it first time in
february 2020.
so to me i think
um
i i think i would definitely admit that
i was very cavalier about the idea of
natural immunity if you're going to rely
on that which from now on
that's obviously a factor right you have
to measure your antibody levels
regularly which i think joe rogan does
for example right he's not just like
well i had covered that's it he's
measuring his antibodies and his team's
antibodies and that's what you got to do
you can't just be like well i had
covered three years ago
i'm going to be fine because these
variants also evade the immunity
right
the other thing i learned as well is
in order to get a very good
natural immunity you have to have had it
badly
and you sort of did have it quite badly
the first time
but i had it very mildly the first time
so you probably had better natural
immunity and it still didn't help it
still didn't help because after i think
natural immunity on average lasts around
six months yeah so by the time you know
the new variant's coming around until
there's a new variant yeah or until
there's a new variant and there's
nothing you can do but
for me when it comes to vaccinations i
have made a decision that i'm going to
get vaccinated probably in around three
months when my natural immunity starts
to
fade and like i said i will be doing you
know the antibody test that's something
i need to get on top of
but i will be getting vaccinated because
for a couple of reasons number one i
can't be getting ill like that again i
can't it's you know because not only
does it have an impact on you it has an
impact on everyone around you
the the fact that i can't i couldn't
work
you know it's it's it's not fine
obviously but if you're employed
there's less it's easier
there's less of a burden etc etc but
you know
we're running a business i can't be on
my ass like i was pretending well yeah
we were off work for three weeks it
wasn't ten days it was three weeks we
didn't work for three weeks and that was
obviously bad however i would say to you
and look i i am going to keep this whole
thing under review
we we know i mean anton made this point
the other day we know a lot of people
who were vaccinated even triple
vaccinated younger than us probably
healthier than us or may you know
whatever who had had it and they had it
just as bad
but statistically speaking
the statistics say you're less likely to
have a serious illness and i did see a
lot of people who were vaccinated around
me have a much less serious illness yeah
as well so
if you i think you statistically
speaking that's fine
i don't think i'm going to get
vaccinated at this i certainly haven't
made that decision
for me i'm going to monitor my antibody
levels and i'm also going to keep an eye
on whatever else is going on the reason
that i am
thinking about getting vaccinated is
your natural immunity can't be boosted
so when it wanes
the only way you can boost is by getting
covered again
whereas at least with vaccines it seems
like if you you could have the natural
immunity in in a few months you get
vaccinated let you just take one dose
that boosts it and then you can boost it
again whenever you need
and also they're putting out vaccines
now that are using more conventional
technology uh as opposed to the mrna one
so that you know that would be
the thing that i'd be interested in
doing because
i am concerned and i think it's it's
it's objectively true that we're not
quite being told the truth about how
safe the
mrna vaccines are uh i'm not saying i
know how safe they are i'm just saying
we're not quite being told the truth you
know the myocarditis thing is not being
properly discussed
and that's a concern and also i you know
i got a message the other day on twitter
from somebody who said um i hope you're
recovering i'm sorry i had covered but
please consider i'm a scientist i got
vaccinated and now i have a seizure a
mini seizure every three minutes
like that every three minutes
right so to me which of those two would
i rather have curve it again the way
that i had it
or have that
that's my concern yeah now
statistically speaking far less likely
but
i'd much rather a higher risk of getting
covered badly the way i had it before
than a much lower risk of something
completely
terrible yeah they're people who've had
legs amputated because of things that
the vaccine has done to them it's been
reported in the news so that's my
concern so i'm gonna wait i'm gonna see
what the other vaccines are
what the safety profile for them looks
like and i'm gonna monitor my antibody
laws yeah well i'm probably gonna get
the chinese one because that's the most
well actually the chinese one is the one
that uses the most conventional
technology yeah it just uses a weakened
version of the noodle jab it's great the
wang jam
jab and i think sputnik might as well
i'm not sure but
like i said the reason that you know
that i'm gonna do it is purely for
myself because
it's just not practical to be out of
action for that long
it just isn't what i'm saying to you is
yeah you could still be out of action
for that long and also unfortunately
getting vaccinated involves a tiny tiny
tiny tiny but nonetheless risk of actual
serious adverse effects yeah so that's
what i'm weighing up yeah and everybody
like we always say on the show
everybody's going to make you got to
make their own decision about it of
course of course but i'm and you know
and we've touched we've touched on it
and we're going to touch on it again the
authoritarian stuff yeah
i'll never be on board with that it's
always always should be
your body your choice you analyze the
risks you read up and then you make a
decision and then after that it's up to
you well see this is another thing that
i i would confess to realizing is i do
think that
all of us now
operate within a bit of a bubble so for
example when i was reading previously to
catching covert again about natural
immunity
there are a lot of studies that show
natural immunity is better 32 times is
the one i read i mean i don't know that
it's 32 times but there's also some
studies that don't show that and they're
not all quite as good as the ones blah
blah blah but basically the
comprehensive analysis is that the the
vaccine is my understanding christakis
wrote about this recently
the vaccine is much better
at preventing serious illness
but they both are similarly effective at
preventing you from catching covert so
if you have natural immunity
you're between 80 to 95 protected
and it's a similar with the vaccine
but the but apparently according to this
uh you're less likely to have a serious
illness now
i wasn't quite aware of that because i
was like well the studies that show
natural immunity is better so i'm fine
right well not quite right there are
people who claimed and you know the us
getting ill coincided with peter
mccullough going on joe rogan's show
you can't get it twice we've never had a
but i have a friend that got it twice
what you have is you have a friend who
thinks he had it twice what happened is
on one or more occasions it's a false
positive test
or
he actually had the dead virus that is
carrying forward somebody in my somebody
in my family circles had covered 19. for
sure had it got sick that person tested
positive intermittently 17 times but
this wasn't just a test positive he got
sick
he recovered and then about seven eight
months later he got sick again tested
positive again and had a much milder
case of it but still got covered twice
yeah it wasn't a second case this is
what's happened for sure yeah there's
about a hundred purported cases like
this in the literature i've looked at
them all
and so when i said well we've caught
covered for a second time uh loads of
people who know it's impossible this guy
on the podcast said it and i was like
well
i have coveted for a second time
right francis has covered for a second
time we know we had covered the first
time because we caught it off a guy
who'd just come back from china in
february 2020 and then when he went to
america and got tested and he was
covered positive right so
we know we had it twice
but because we all live in this bubble
where we we want to believe certain
things more than others
i think most of us now we don't really
follow the evidence
enough and we follow our own biases too
much and i and i did start to see that
in how people were responding even
people who know and trust me and i was
like guys i do have it for a second time
you like if you've trusted me for the
last three years you can kind of know
i'm not making it up
but a lot of people were you know they
don't want it to be true and i get it
because
here's the truth francis
we're all very [ __ ] tired of this
[ __ ] yeah we're all at we want it to end
everyone whether you're vaccinated or
not vaccinated or whatever we all want
the [ __ ] to end and that's why people
attach
their emotion of i just wanted to stop
to various things so people who are
pro-vaccine attach
their desire for things to stop to the
fact that not enough people are
vaccinated even though in this country
it's like 92
of adults over 18 are vaccinated
but they believe that some people
believe that the reason covert goes on
is there too many unvaccinated people
which is [ __ ] complete [ __ ] and
there are also people who are leaning
towards vaccine hesitancy or being
anti-back so like they don't want to
believe anything about they don't even
want to believe it exists because they
just want this [ __ ] to end and i
understand that i do yeah and and that's
it's such a good point because it's
we're all tired of this and i use the
word tired
it is most accurate sense
we're just tired it's been two [ __ ]
years yeah of constantly thinking about
this of it dominating the news of it
disrupting our lives of us not being
able to plan of us feeling you know that
the world is changing and we we we're
looking at a world that is
unrecognizable to the one that we used
to know
two short years ago
and so you look for anything to confirm
your bias
but the reality is is
i remember i was talking to a friend
about this at the very start of the
pandemic and he made this point and it's
such a good point he went
just as we live in a post-aids world
we're going to live in a post-covert
world and unfortunately we're going to
have to accept that there's always going
to be a new variant there's always going
to be
you know
people getting sick there's it's
something that the nhs is going to have
to cope with i don't know how it's going
to cope with it but it's going to have
to
we're now living in a post-covered world
and then the sooner we come to accept i
don't know about that
i don't know that we live in a
post-covet world i think we're still in
the pandemic yeah yeah in the crutches
yeah okay but eventually we're gonna
have to accept that this is part of our
world yeah and we need to the reason i
say we're not in the post-covered world
francis is i've been talking to a lot of
scientists because i've had the time
yeah this is the other thing i realized
is no one has time to research things
properly i certainly didn't so we go
with headlines or newspaper articles
when you actually you have to do
research you have to look at studies you
have to talk to people who understand
what's going on
so i've been talking to scientists and
one of the things that people have said
to me
there's a russian canadian scientist
called yuridegan who was the one of the
originators of the labley hypothesis the
idea that
the og curve the original covet came
from a lab in wuhan
well was that his rap name the og
the gangster
but um
he says i'm not saying it's true i'm not
saying i know i don't have a new way of
evaluating it but there's some evidence
genetically the omicron
transition through mice somehow
okay and what that likely means is that
omicron was made in a lab
quite possibly in a lab in south africa
complete people please stop [ __ ]
making viruses in labs i did suggest
this to him he he's very much on board
but he's not the one in charge for
answers but basically what what people
are saying is there are dozens of these
labs where these [ __ ] idiots
are doing gain of function research
gainer functional research being you
take a virus you play around with it
until a virus that only affects paths
suddenly can infect humans now that's
good right so
uh to suggest that this is over or we're
about to live in a post-covered world is
it i think a possible scenario but i
think another scenario is that there are
other variants that leak out of other
labs
or other variants that develop naturally
through mutation
and there's
[Music]
it's true that over time generally the
trend tends to be the viruses become
more contagious and less lethal
but it doesn't have to
there's no there's no guarantee that
that's going to happen
it could be contagious and lethal for a
bit before he kills off everyone he's
gonna kill off and then be replaced so
that's my one reason that i would still
consider getting vaccinated because
you saw with people who were able to get
the third jab
and it topped up their immunity with
natural immunity you can't do that so
i don't think we're we're out of the
woods by any stretch of the imagination
yeah i i take your point but what i mean
by postcode it was is inaccurate but
what we need to do is we need to accept
that this thing is here to stay this
idea that we're going to eradicate it
this idea that it's it's not going to
become
you know endemic
it's just ridiculous it's just
ridiculous we are going to have to
accept it we're going to have to live
with it we need better technology in
order to deal with it you and i have
spoken about this many times i have no
problem with having some kind of
breathalyzer
type test that you you do if you want to
go into a restaurant or a bar or you
know breathe into it if that stops
someone from getting hospitalized yeah
and i've got no problem at all no me
neither you know it should be they
should what they need to do is develop
some kind of test where you just spit in
the test tube and it's literally lights
up red or green or something yeah that's
it and if that was accurate and if that
was readily available and it was cheap
and you could mass produce it i've got
no problem doing that i i'm against the
authoritarianism but to me
checking whether you have a disease yeah
i don't like i saw some people going oh
gb news are now uh testing people before
before putting them on the set i'm not
doing that i was like why
why wouldn't you make sure that you're
not to infect other people because as we
know from our own experience
asymptomatic transition transmission is
possible no one at that party had
covered visibly yeah
but
pretty much everyone except anton got
infected which means
but
yeah so that's what we need to do we
need to have better technology
we need to and it's just going to become
a factor in our lives well they while we
were ill actually they approved
monoclonal antibodies which we've known
for a long time prevent you from getting
ill if you take it in the first couple
of days the reason that they only give
it to super vulnerable people in the uk
is it's expensive uh it's like two
thousand dollars for one i think rogan
took it yeah rogan took and he didn't
get ill dana white the same i would have
taken it if we had access to in the uk
we just don't have access to it if we'd
taken that we wouldn't have got ill yeah
almost certainly uh they've also just
approved a couple of antiviral drugs
that can be taken as a cocktail to again
prevent serious illness but again
they're only giving it to the vulnerable
again because it's expensive
now this is i think one of the reasons
that they're pushing the vaccine so hard
is
they claim it's cheaper i don't know
whether it's true by the way there's a
lot of a lot of questions about that but
apparently it's cheaper so that would
make sense if you can prevent people
from getting ill with a cheaper thing is
better than
from a financial perspective anyway
uh so
new drugs are coming out new treatments
are going to come out and this is really
maybe
how the answer is going to be sure
everyone's going to get it but almost no
one's going to die from it because we
have ways of treating it i hope that's
the path that it ends up being because
look the reality is
people talk about the unvaccinated
whatever the overwhelming majority of
people who are currently unvaccinated
are going to stay unvaccinated that's
the reality you're not going to change
those people's minds
and you're certainly not going to change
those people's minds did you see that um
that press release from the united
states government
about saying that you know the people
who are vaccinated you will be fine and
blah blah blah the unvaccinated you will
have
a rough time no it's not a rough time
they said this this new year will be a
year of sickness and death yeah yeah
whatever something horrible
and you just look at that and you go
how is that going to win hearts and
minds well it's not tony blair calling
people stupid and selfish for not
getting vaccinated well they're not
stupid they've got a different opinion
now you may disagree with it like we
disagreed with you invading iraq right
yeah but but it doesn't mean that
they're stupid right and
uh austria is fining unvaccinated people
all of this angriest apparently i have
poor completely i mean it's it's it's
wrong and this the point that you know
carissa veliz made if you remember when
we had her on the show and it's a point
i reinforce in my book is you don't know
how technology will be used
later down the line
the dutch had a very good system of
statistics they had a guy called lens
who was one of the pioneers of
statistics and he wanted to build a
system that followed people from cradle
to grave and in his senses there were a
lot of questions and there was data
collection about your religious
affiliation but also your ancestry and
things like where your grandparents
lived now in contrast in france they had
made a decision um since 1872 not to
collect that kind of data for privacy
reasons
and so when the nazis arrived to france
and asked you know where the jews they
said you know we have no idea how many
jews we have let alone where they live
so good luck with that and the nazis had
to depend on either jewish people um
turning themselves in or having
neighbors neighbors to turn them in
which was very inefficient and the
result is that in the netherlands the
nazis found and killed 73 of the jewish
population and in france 25 of the
jewish population and the difference is
hundreds of thousands of people
so creating vaccine passport databases
and all of that stuff you have no idea
how that's going to be used that's why
those lines must never be crossed but i
don't mind spitting in a test tube that
just gets thrown in the bin without
being attached to my name
before i enter a large venue i've got no
problem with that in fact while you're
in the middle of this i don't think it's
a bad idea at all i wish you know if we
if we had something very simple very
cheap very easy to use at our live show
great yeah if we could do that with our
guests to make and with ourselves to
make sure that we're not passing we've
got people coming in here in the 80s
i don't want to give covert to someone
in their 80s they could die yeah exactly
and you know you know we had people
saying you know there was a couple of
people going oh do you do you agree with
you know people taking my temperature
before i go into a venue and i was like
yes yeah we do agree
i i don't know how effective checking
your temperature is you could still have
coverage you can still have code so
that's why i'm saying you need good
tests not testing people's temperature
but also as well if you've got a fever
you shouldn't be around people anyway i
agree well i mean but but you've got to
remember francis it's like
you had you were not feeling well yeah
and you went to a comedy show yeah with
80 other people in a tiny comedy club
because
people make mistakes people think they
don't have covered they don't think they
have covered because they don't want to
think that they have covered human
beings are not necessarily entirely
consistent and logical even with their
own beliefs agreed but if i went to the
venue and they took the temperature to
go look your feet you've got your
temperature's a bit high we're not
letting you in i would
i would accept that
yeah i would accept that and be like
well that's absolutely fine you know i
just
i don't i i think the way that
germany new zealand australia australia
austria
italy italy france france it's basically
everyone yeah everybody exactly
not only
yeah not only
you know the authoritarian it's
dangerous it's
what we're doing is we're playing with
things that we should not be playing
with
and it's especially blind yeah
when you play with things you shouldn't
yeah exactly come on man yeah yeah
that's the covert it work particularly
with when it concerns western liberal
democracies
but also it doesn't work yeah it doesn't
work it's discriminatory for no good
reason vaccine passports are moronic
because they don't prove that you don't
have coven yeah vaccinated people can
pass it on they can catch it testing
checking whether someone is vaccinated
isn't ensuring that people are safe so
if while there's a super contagious
variant like omicron
we we have a test where you've got green
in yeah
great
great to me that makes sense i've got
absolutely no problem with that all this
other authoritarian [ __ ] can get in the
bin but it's also as well as they're
bringing authoritarianism through the
back door like my friend went to new
york
went to a conference
took her temperature she was fine
and then
they scanned her face yeah and she was
like hang on a second they were oh don't
worry about it madam you can go through
it she went why are you scanning my face
you've just taken my data yeah what's
going to happen to that data absolutely
it's going to get then sold on so just
sitting for those people who are worried
about it it's like could you say this
yeah they could scan your face 20 years
time you want to have life insurance or
they'll go well unfortunately you've got
a genetic predisposition i don't know to
ms therefore we can't we can't give you
the life insurance so how do you know
that absolutely
absolutely so all of those
doors
that are being opened and i'm glad to
see
people that we respect tremendously like
jordan peterson and douglas murray who
who i believe i don't know about douglas
i suspect he's vaccinated i don't know i
don't i haven't asked him and i don't
think he's talked about it publicly but
let's assume that he is jordan is i
think double vaccinated
and
i think there was even a point where
jordan said to people just get the damn
jab or something yeah and let's get back
to normal but
we can all see now that the promises
that we were made
about
people taking the vaccine means freedom
well these things don't seem to be that
correlated uh if you look on the
continent where people are getting
vaccinated just like in the uk not quite
the same levels they're they're having
all of these
the all of this authoritarianism and i
think
we're really in a dangerous place uh and
just and i think there will be people
who who who are thinking oh you had
covered badly hahaha
well it doesn't change my opinion of any
of this other stuff
it doesn't at all yeah you know and
you've got to remember as well like sure
you can force people to do things you
don't want to do and then you might you
and i might not have got ill or whatever
and not go ill badly but what about all
the people who are suffering as a result
of all these measures
medically physically mentally
financially in every way
what me not getting ill for a couple of
weeks is that worth it
i i don't personally feel entitled to
ruin other people's lives so that i
don't have a bad flu for a couple of
weeks i don't
and it's also as well you look at some
of these you know some of the measures
that are brought in by these european
countries they're anti-scientific italy
demanding you wear masks outside
when the science says that your risk of
contracting covid outside a minimal
0.0 so masks aren't going to do anything
yet they insist most marks don't work
yeah exactly
no matter how badly i had covered i
still i'm able to understand the data
yeah most of the cloth masks that people
wear don't work they said this there's
this crazy woman on cnn called lyanna
when yeah who's always like more more
vaccine more locked down more everything
she came out and said it while we were
ill on cnn that masks cloth masks don't
stop covid
cloth masks are not appropriate for this
pandemic it was it's not appropriate for
omicron it was not appropriate for delta
alpha or any of the previous variants
either because we're dealing with
something that's airborne
cloth masks don't stop covet right
and i've been saying this for a long
time they don't now there are some masks
that do help and 95 masks yeah they do
work to reduce you transmitting it to
other people but also to slightly to
reduce you the risk of you catching it
so people need to understand the nuances
of things and and like i said you and i
were cavalier about
not understanding certain things not
doing the research and i think a lot of
people on all sides of the argument are
doing that you know
there are people who think i someone
messaged me the other day a friend from
comedy uh who
who called me an anti-vaxxer which i'm
not i've always said vulnerable people
should take the vaccine
but also said that
when i explained to him that i'm not and
we were having the conversation he was
like well all the people in hospital are
unvaccinated
well that's completely not true right
now statistically speaking the data is
suggesting that you're much less likely
to be hospitalized if you're vaccinated
and that's true
if that's true great people should make
their own decision about that but my
point is people on both sides of the
argument they're not doing enough
research and i include myself on this
until recently
to understand what they're actually
talking about because we all just want
it to be over and so we all look for a
scapegoat
you know the scapegoat is china or the
scapegoat is the scientist or the
scapegoat is the unvaccinated the
scapegoat is
you know the great reset or whatever you
know everyone wants to have like an
explanation of there's a small group of
evil people who we can blame on this
well
pandemics happen they've always happened
throughout history usually we blame the
jews
now we've leveled up and we're blaming
people who are
unvaccinated people just need to take a
step back and realize all of this
happens man
most people are going to catch it you're
not going to get away from it protect
yourself as best you can by improving
your physical mental health if you want
to get vaccinated get vaccinated
that's it
part of the problem as well is before
the pandemic there was this
air of you know we've kind of conquered
nature
we've conquered nature you know we're
above nature yeah and as a result of
that there's there's we don't have to
worry we use nature for our ends
well the pandemic came along and
reminded everybody you ain't in control
of [ __ ] mate yeah well i remember your
dad came around here
a few weeks before we got covered and we
were talking about this and i said to
him oh you know
no disrespect but you're older than us
obviously uh and you would have lived
through the hong kong flu that that was
in the uk and he was like oh yeah
i don't even remember it
but it was
it was it was a there was a pandemic of
an airborne virus but because we didn't
feel that we could do as much
people just got on with life and i
remember him saying that he took a week
off school to look after my grandfather
who had it yeah and that's just what you
did you just coped and you got on with
it right
you manned up
you man up you have a lucas and you walk
it off and three weeks later you're just
fine yeah
once you've had medical intervention in
your case yeah absolutely
but yeah and
it
what we need to do is we need and it's
very difficult to say this we need to
take the emotion out of this
we need to take the emotion out of it
and try and be more rational more
scientific and the government need to
take responsibility and the media and
the media and the way they have ramped
it up the way they've politicized it the
way they've used it to you know
get clicks sell copy or whatever it may
be that
it's it's unforgivable but also this is
one of the other things that people you
know we put out
my the thread that i wrote earlier last
year as a video
uh which has now been censored by
youtube which have made it age
restricted even though there's nothing
too
inappropriate for people under 18 apart
from the bouncing arses at the end when
you're in the rap video yeah it's a
great video go check it out
you know
one of the things that
experts and scientists and particularly
governments
have done is
they've lacked humility
and they
have chosen the path of certainty in
order to persuade people but what they
don't understand is if you say to people
this is a hundred percent true you must
do what i say
and then you're consistently proven to
not quite be right about what you say
eventually people are going to tune you
out
and i think that is what's happened
because you know they said don't wear a
mask then they said where am i then they
said the vaccine is is this then it's
that they made a lot of claims about
things they said oh we just need to give
it to the vulnerable
we gave it to the vulnerable they're
like no no everyone needs to take it
right
then they said i mean there was a clip
of rachel meadow
huge in america saying if you get the
vaccine you can't pass it on
well you can
now we know that the vaccines work well
enough that the virus
stops with every vaccinated
a vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else
it cannot use a vaccinated person as a
host to go get more people
right and when you get all of the stuff
coming out
it's fine because science it works that
way in the it never knows the exact
answer and you're always feeling in the
dark for what the actual answer is
but you've got to retain that humility
you've got to say look we don't know
exactly currently our best estimate is
that if you get the vaccine you're going
to be protected it may be that not
everybody is right and it's the same and
peter mccullough who i have some issues
with because right as you and i had
covered for the second time he was
saying you can't catch it and doing it
without any humility on joe rogan he was
quite arrogant about it at the same time
two weeks later when it was clear that
you can catch omicron even if you've got
natural immunity to be fair to me came
out on twitter and said so
so that's how it should be people need
to on both sides need to take that
certainty out of it you don't know
even if you're a scientist you don't
know
you just don't know exactly so you can
give people a best estimate
but you can't claim that you know and
then when people don't believe you
because you keep getting things wrong be
upset and it's also as well
there's a lot of scientists particularly
in the uk who need to take
responsibility for the modeling and
modeling these huge numbers of people
dying they did it with omicron they did
it at the start terrifying people
and then
it doesn't come to fruition
but we go back to these people again and
again and neil ferguson
at what point are we just going to say
just shut up
well one of the things that happened
while we were real is that fraser nelson
of the spectator had an exchange on
twitter with one of the modelers
in which it essentially became clear
there's a very good spectator article
that fraser wrote about his experience
of talking to this guy it became clear
that when they do models
basically i think the government asks
them for the worst possible scenario and
then they tell them the worst possible
scenario without saying this is actually
statistically incredibly unlikely here's
the most likely scenario which is much
milder so basically for the last year
two years it's basically the government
have said what's the worst thing that
could happen and they've gone everyone's
gonna die
and then we we have everyone's gonna die
lockdown and restrictions and whatever
because we're operating not on the most
likely scenario but on the worst
possible case so there's something wrong
there
of course there's something wrong
there's something wrong with them
because it's not just the impact on the
government
it's it's the impact on ordinary
people's lives
where there are there are people who are
more neurotic they're more anxious
they're more risk-averse
and you're terrifying them yeah and
you're terrifying these people and it's
just not the effect it's having on their
lives it's the effect it's having on
their relationships it's the effect it's
having on businesses people not going to
coffee shops restaurants not going here
not going there
this is having a huge effect
and we're not talking about it the fact
is
i can't remember now what the stat is
tens of thousands of kids are no longer
on the school roll
yeah we don't know what's happened to
them we just we don't know yeah what
effect is that going to have 10 20 years
down the line well what effect is that
going to have now what's happened to
them they could have been killed by by
uh someone in their home or whatever we
just don't know we don't know right
these kids have literally disappeared
off the road so to me that's pretty bad
here's an unpleasant stat if you go into
secondary school being behind
your peers yeah the statistic is that
you're never gonna you're never gonna
catch up yeah that's a step it's a
famous stat in education you're just
never gonna count very unlikely yeah
yeah highly unlikely to but we have now
a generation of children yeah
yeah but they're all stupid now so
that's fine it's fine mate well listen
mate speaking of covid and you know our
recovery i'm you know i'm really
enjoying me back to work as you can see
i've got a bit of a lingering cough i'm
not infectious for people who are
worried about me coughing whatever but
um you know we've done an hour and i do
feel like my energy levels are not
certainly not what they used to be in
terms of doing this so i think we'll
wrap it up here we'll do a few questions
for locals
and if people have got a bunch of
questions we'll maybe do a follow-up
conversation depending on whether people
find this interesting or not but in the
meantime thank you for watching uh join
our locals if you want to see the
questions that people have asked and our
answers and we'll see you very soon with
normal episodes uh uh that we will be
coming out soon see my brain is not
working so yeah so it's normal episodes
which are always on a wednesday and sun
and sunday
7 p.m uk time 2 p.m eastern standard uh
friday saturday and thursday see i got
it wrong there raw shows again at the
same time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below